s
que Mélanie Joly met les pieds
en Ukraine. Et
ça en est tout un.(déclics d'ap)
À l'instar de plusieurs pays
qui ont déjà ou dédédédédédédédr
diplomate en chef à Kiev,
la ministre est en mission
de solidarité.
- I come here as a friend.
- Dans un pays qui, aux dires
à tout moment par la Russie,
le Canada tenaitéiéiéiéiéitérer
son appui indéfectible.
MÉLANIE JOLY,
- Bien, c'est sûr qu'on est
êêêêêmement préoccupés
par le fait qu'il y ait
plus de 100 000 soldatrerererer.
Et donc, dans les circonstances,
on prend la menace russe
très au sérieux.
- Le risque d'une attaininininin
l'OTAN, qu'Ottawa avise
désormais ses citoyens d'éviter
tout voyage non essentiela a a é
des Ukrainiens, la vie continue
un peu comme si de rien n'était,
se préparent au pire,
en remettant en état de vieux
abris souterrains qui remontent
àe e e e e e de la guerre froid.
"Aujourd'hui, c'est contre
une attaque de l'ancienne
mère-patri
- Bam! Bam! Bam! Bam!
- Et juste au cas où, depuis
l'automne, des centaines
comme réservistes. Vlas est
me d d d d d des 130 nouvelles
brigades de territoire, créées
pour épauler l'armée en casusus.
"Les pays de l'OTAN
ttttttttttttttront pas pour nou,
c'est clair, dit-il.
Donc, nous devons ê s s s s s s"
Il fallait s'y at
le premier ministre de l'Ukraine
a profité de la visite de
sa cause en privé. L'Ukraine
l l l l l l l'équipement et
des armes à ses partenaires,
ce à quoi le Canada
- Et donc,i i i i i i i que,
pour nous, c'est important
de fairecicicicicicicicicicicic.
- Keep foward! Let's go!
The show must go on!
- Mais ladadadadadadadadadadadae
de l'Ukraine demeure la mission
unifiée : 200 soldats canadiens
qui, à longueur d'année,
une mission que Mélanie Joly
ira visiter demain
et quiuvuvuvuvuvuvuvuvuvuvuvuvu.
Et de tous les alliés
de l'OTAN, c'est stotototototots
compté le plus pour défendre
son éventuelle adhésion
à l'alliance.
- Novrvrvrvrvrvrvrvrvrvrvrvrvrve
joindre l'OTAN. En même temps
il doit avoir des réformes
démocratiques qui ont lieu ici.
(tir)
- Bien qu'on soit encore loin
la Russie exige la garantie
e e e e e e e e e ça n'arrivera
jamais.
Le porte-parole du président
Vladimir Poutine s'e
de fabriquer un prétexte pour
envahir son voisin.
La Russie prépare la riposte,
si elle n'obtient pas
Ici Tamara Alteresco,anananana.